en territoire ami
[Musique]
à perpignan qui a déjà fait le choix du
changement le maire louis aliot du
rassemblement national
perpignan je ne doute pas que demain
marine le jura pour la france
ses partisans à la voit déjà à l'elysée
la candidate promet de mieux s'occuper
du bien-être des français que le
président actuel si emmanuel macron
avait enrichi le pays pardon
mais je ne parlerais pas de pouvoir
d'achat
l'une des priorités de la population
marine le pen a joué cette carte à fond
en sillonnant la france
[Applaudissements]
la rencontre des français ordinaires de
ceux qui ont du mal à boucler les fins
de mois et puis qu'avec ta guerre en
ukraine on rentre aussi dans une période
où on nous promet une hausse généralisée
de tous les produits de consommation
courants y compris alimentaires donc
c'est à cela que marine le pen s'adresse
et il remarque qu'elle se dévoile
davantage qu il y a cinq ans pour se
donner un visage plus humain pour faire
contraste avec la dureté de ses
propositions et puis du même coup comme
eric zemmour est venu dans le paysage
avec des propositions du ans mais aussi
un style qui est extrêmement tranchant
marine le pen a pu se payer le luxe si
jose vient de dire à propos d'eric
zemmour et ses propositions enfin c'est
pas humain il est trop dur
même si sur le fond marine le pen a
beaucoup en commun avec le candidat de
reconquête par exemple sur l'immigration
deviendront français sont et seulement
ce qu'ils méritent dans le domaine et
sur la forme elle a poursuivi la
dédiabolisation du parti hérité de son
père jean-marie en étant plus posé bien
des électeurs vont voter le pen pour la
première fois
dis jamais
mais
maintenant il ya pire y avait moi je
veux voter marine le pen parce que
pendant cinq ans on a eu macro mais on
ne veut pas ou à bormes à croire au
gouvernement ça suffit
l'extrême droite gagnerait en popularité
en france au delà du seuil habituel qui
comprend notamment les classes ouvrières
populaire
le rassemblement national a déjà en tête
la bataille du deuxième tour tout en
avertissant rien est encore joué pour le
premier tour marine le pen lance un
appel à la mobilisation
elle invite tous ceux qui croient en son
projet à se rendre aux urnes en disant
quand on est un patriote on ne
s'abstient pas ici aux libéraux à du
canada à perpignan